president biden and kamala harris
claiming democracy is under attack a
full year after january 6. and the
speeches were music to the ears of
liberal news anchors who lapped up every
word
the president of the united states
delivering an extremely powerful
very very significant speech it was a
rhetorically very forceful speech this
may well become the strongest speech
he's ever given
it was from the heart this was the
clearest dissection of trump's big lie
we've heard from president biden this
speech by president biden was really a
remarkable one extraordinary remarks up
at the capitol the most powerful and
consequential speech of his presidency
to date if you think that speech was
partisan
then you believe the former president's
lie
and i wonder what the media will think
of this cringe-worthy moment
we're privileged to have a contribution
from one of the great creative talents
of our time
lin manuel
miranda
may his beautiful words be an
inspiration to us
i call your attention too a new year
brings hope for the future new energy to
face the tasks ahead of us and a renewed
promise to strengthen the foundations of
our democracy
[Music]
dear theodosia what to say to you
you have my eyes you have your mother's
name
not a parody very real greg
yeah you know this is basically
christmas
at cnn
you know it's like all their show
producers just got free subscriptions to
barely legal you know and you got to
remember
they were bragging about their ratings
the day after the riot they weren't
expressing outrage they were expressing
excitement that it was the biggest
ratings day ever because they realize
that their success is predicated on
americans being at each other's throat
we've talked about this division
is what pays for their so-called news
division and it helps pay for tuban's
porn and stelter's hoagies so cnn has to
go all in on this because they are in a
they're in a huge mess they have you
know multiple anchors accused of sexual
harassment they're like two producers
accused of a legend like deviant
pedophile crap that would make john
wayne gacy blush uh so they have to they
have to instead obsess over hey did fox
news call it an insurrection or not well
we haven't called it an insurrection
because no one's been found guilty of it
but i understand why you would why you'd
be chasing that idea lastly again i go
back to the coordination factor you got
the new republic usa today ap hollywood
reporter they're all doing stories in
which the media is interviewing the
media and it tells you that thing that i
always say before that nothing happens
in this world unless it happens to the
media they have to be the center of the
story the fearless media battling ptsd
to revisit this trauma that's why they
didn't care about the riots they didn't
care about portland because it wasn't
about them but this is about them and
their political heroes and dana this is
the only story that isn't bad for
democrats so the media again is kind of
a circle they just keep peddling it it's
like who came up with the big lie was it
the democrats or
the media they just keep repeating it
well i i agree it was a strong speech i
mean he obviously
put some time into it and they rehearsed
it like it was a teleprompter speech
they had it this organized he wasn't
even late to give this speech i mean
they got we got the two-minute warning
just as nine o'clock started this
morning i mean that's uh when you know
that they are ready to man basically
orchestrate the whole day including
lin-manuel miranda
for example i want to say one thing
about that suggestion that if you um
think that that speech was partisan then
you must believe the lie that's
ridiculous never believed that
never believed that the election was
stolen never said that
and i can still
listen to that speech but don't just
take it to from me
when when biden left statuary hall he
walks out two reporters are there they
shout two questions to him the first two
questions were
about
why he gave such a divisive speech
okay so maybe you think those reporters
believe the big lie i guess i don't know
that's kind of ridiculous i also want to
mention one other thing there's
something that all of these reporters
are missing and that the answer to
making sure this never happens again
is right there for the democrats taking
because the republicans have come
forward and said we want to clarify
the electoral count act they like how
it's done it's called the electoral
count reform act which would clarify the
language so that it's no not ambiguous
at all so that this could never happen
again mitch mcconnell said we're ready
to do this today president biden could
have said today
take him up on it that i'm going to stop
by his office on the way out of here we
can work out the details we could have
that done by monday but instead they
want to do
full cell federalization of voting
rights which is obviously not going to
pass and it's going to just end up
hurting them in the long run
instead harold they had to shoehorn that
ghastly lip sync in which did look like
lip-syncing from part of the cast of
hamilton
yeah that was a little odd um
but i i do think you know it is it it's
i think it's hard for any any news
organization to legitimately uh come uh
make claims uh complaining about bias i
mean i think we all at some point
practice it practice it a little freely
uh i think perhaps on today uh there's
some there's probably more pent-up
resentment around it because the issue
is such a serious one uh i probably have
been better if if you know if the
president had not given uh uh such uh uh
i thought there were elements of the
speech that were were a little more
divisive than need be but i thought the
speech overall was was a powerful one i
think dana's right you could disagree
with the speech and not believe that the
election was fairly and rightly won by
joe biden i do hope that one of the
things we take away from all this is is
one of the lessons we learned just
earlier late last year rather when we
saw elections happen in virginia new
jersey and voters went out
and cast their cast their ballots for
the persons they wanted to represent
them as governor uh and democrats didn't
fare well it's that's how you and a
democracy in a republic that's how you
show politicians that they're not
performing the way you want them to
perform so i hope we hope we take that
lesson from today as much as anything
jesse wrap us up
january 6th is the left's new july 4th
they can have it i'll celebrate america
in the summer with the rest of the
normal people joe biden famously said of
rudy giuliani guy says three things noun
verb and 9 11. now he's guilty in all
his team noun verb january 6 because
digging what else are they going to talk
about they can't report the real news
about inflation and covid closing down
schools and open borders real news hurts
democrats only the fake news helps the
democratic party they have to
resuscitate the bad guy because the hero
joe's not getting the base fired up
i saw a transcript from a show on msnbc
for the whole year they mentioned
donald trump's name over 11 000
only mention biden's name a little over
four thousand times wow
he's not a genie you can't keep saying
trump and he's gonna come out of a lamp
here's the thing
he actually might beat joe biden if the
election was held emerson says he'd beat
joe biden if the election was held today
so you know what keep saying his name
might hurt you
boom hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else